Speaker 1: Gavin Newsom continues to be brutal
and ruthless in what I believe are all the right
ways. He had that extraordinary interview
with Fox News propagandist Sean HANNITY,
which we covered. He was interviewed again, this
time by former Biden press Secretary Jen Psaki
on her MSNBC show. And I want to play a particular
clip from that interview that a number of you sent
me regarding mental illness and a mental health
crisis. Gavin Newsom blames Fox News in this clip
for making the mental health crisis worse.
Listen to what he says. I want to know your
thoughts and I'll give you mine. Take a listen.
Speaker 2: Entertainment wing, particularly of the
Republican Party, the surround sound on Fox with
these you know, I don't even like say his name
Tucker Carlson or that other I don't even know
the guy from. And there's just like they're all
the same. And what American news and Newsmax and
what they're doing to divide this country into,
you know, illusion rules, not facts.
Speaker 3: Do you occasionally turn on
Fox News time and see what happens? Just to see?
Speaker 2: Not occasionally. Every night.
Speaker 3: Every night. And do you
think Democrats should still be
appearing on Fox or should they not be appearing?
Speaker 2: It contributes to the mental health
crisis in the state. So on the basis of one's
own personal conditions, I would not recommend
it. My staff is quite literally trying to have
interventions with me about it. They say I'm too
obsessed with it, but I need to understand it.
Speaker 3: You want to know
what the other side thinks?
Speaker 1: So he says. Gavin Newsom says Fox
News and other right wing trash media contribute
to the mental health crisis potentially causing
mental illness. Is that just a funny line or is
it actually a real possibility? Well, there's a
number of ways in which he may actually be on to
something. There is an argument that by exposing
viewers to misinformation and fear mongering
and fomenting polarization based on lies and
being. Scared of scapegoats, that they establish
that they are actually changing the perception
of reality that their viewers have, and that this
thus affects their emotional well-being and social
relationships and makes Fox viewers more prone
to anxiety, depression, paranoia, potentially
activating a latent mental health issue like
schizophrenia or whatever the case may be. I'm not
saying that's the case, but I'm saying is there an
argument to be made here that Gavin Newsom might
be right? For example, there are studies that
have found Fox News viewers are more likely to
believe false or unsupported claims about COVID,
about climate change, about immigration and the
dangerous brown people that are coming here or
election fraud or whatever. Once they believe
those false things, it can cause confusion,
distrust, fear and denial of scientific realities,
distrust of expert advice, for example. All of
those things can impact the health, including the
mental health of an individual. Another example
Fox News will often portray certain groups of
people on the opinion shows in particular, but
on the news shows as well immigrants, Muslims,
liberals, protesters, Marxists, anarchists, as
Donald Trump used to say, as threats, enemies and
criminals. And this induces fear and anger or even
hatred. This increases stress levels, cortisol,
etc., impacts empathy, fuels aggression.
This can lead to a mental health crisis,
etc.. So I don't have to belabor it, but
is there something to what Gavin Newsom
is saying there? Ultimately, obviously, the
impact of Fox News on mental health depends
on a number of factors and contextual realities
and the preexisting mental state of those who
are watching Fox News in the first place. I'm
not pretending. Fox News is giving everybody
mental illness, but by any means. But is there
something to what Gavin Newsom said? Let me know
in a comment. Let me know in an email. Let me know
on threads where you can find me a David Pakman.